a new trailer for armored Core 6 has
just rolled onto the scene and I have so
much new gameplay to break down for you
here but this video will also get you up
to speed with how old armored Core games
used to play because I want everyone to
understand just how far this Series has
come so if you've never played an
armored Core game before then this is
the video for you and even if you're
familiar with the series there are huge
secrets in this trailer that you would
have missed unless you watched it frame
by frame
so let's break it down but not before we
catch up on the story The Trailer starts
with our approach to Rubicon which is
this devastated planet that was
essentially raised to Ash with the
outbreak of a new substance called Coral
we're close to Rubicon wait
we're talking about us here we do play
as a mercenary For Hire after all
Handler Walter verified
activating cerebral Coral control device
it seems we even have a Handler called
Walter and we're essentially being used
as their attack dog
Coral that new dangerous pink reddish
substance that was discovered on Rubicon
is playing a part in the cerebral
control of our character who is an
augmented human piloting an armored
Corps
augmented human
c4621 has awakened it's nothing new in
the armored Core Series for the AC pilot
to be augmented in some way throughout
the series there's often been something
called the human plus program which was
this experimental procedure that
cybernetically meshed the human with
their armored Core to improve
performance and then in armored Core 4
there were Lynx Pilots whose nerves were
literally linked with their Max
Electronics so I assume something
similar is the case here in armored Core
6. we are almost certainly an augmented
human because it gives us greater
control of our neck
but speaking of control let's talk
gameplay to date I've played these seven
armored Core games so I'll be showing my
clips from these games in order to get
everyone up to speed and on the same
page regarding how armored Core has
traditionally been played because in
some ways armored Core 6 appears to be
very similar to these older games but in
others it appears to be very different
so the first thing I want to talk about
is boosting
boosting in armored Core is when you
press a button to activate your
thrusters which significantly increases
your movement speed in Old AC games you
can either boost along the ground and
try to avoid enemy fire that way or tap
the Boost button again to enter a
boosted flying mode and this ability to
fight in three dimensions all while
handling multiple weapons at the same
time and managing a lot of different
systems all at once that is at the very
core of armored cause combat now in
previous games being Airborne like this
is demanding it drains your energy bar
seen on the left here think of energy as
the equivalent of the stamina bar in
Dark Souls energy is drained by certain
actions like moving with your boosters
or when you fire certain energy Weaponry
or by activating unique abilities and
it's recovered passively whenever you're
not boosting especially if you're
completely standing still like this but
if you mess up and you completely drain
your energy bar your regen rate will be
severely punished and enemies will make
a quick work of you while you stand
there trying to get it back thus it's
extremely important to watch your energy
in these games and unless your AC is
specifically built to be light with a
powerful energy generator and efficient
boosters it's actually really difficult
to achieve sustained flight in most of
these games in the first set of armored
Core games which I consider to be all of
these ones efficient movement was
achieved by doing something called bunny
hopping which required you to activate
and deactivate your boosters like this
this allowed you to ascend and be
avoidant of enemies and then you could
recover your energy as you free fall
down only to start the process again and
maintain your momentum when you hit the
ground as long as you time it properly
your bunny hopping but then in armored
Core 4 the series was revamped in a
really big way and Max overall became
faster more energy efficient and more
Airborne so the whole bunny hopping
thing wasn't really required and in
armored Core 4 the player was even given
a dedicated button for side boosting
which allowed you to trade a chunk of
energy for this instantaneous speed
boost in any direction this change to
the game was huge and while I kind of
missed the whole bunny hopping thing as
I enjoyed doing that side boosting was
new and that also required a lot of
skill and timing and it just allowed the
game to be played at a faster pace and
when I say faster I really mean faster
armored Core 4 requires crazy reflexes
at times it's frantic it's dizzying the
speed you play at and that's especially
true when you're fighting another Mech
that uses all of the same side boosting
techniques as you do and then there was
armored Core 5 which was way more
grounded and way more weightier and very
divisive from what I hear anyway the
reason I'm talking about boosting is
because the big question for many fans
was how fast armored Core 6 would play
would it have this methodical momentum
like the first generation of armored
Core games or would combat be frantic
like in armored Core 4 or would things
be more grounded and slow like in
armored Core 5 and now that we've
finally got gameplay of armored Core 6
we can answer those questions and I
think that armored Core 6 kind of looks
like it has elements of all of the
previous armored Core games I can
actually comprehend what's going on on
screen so it can't be as fast as armored
Core 4 but it does retain the side
boosting ability from armored Core 4 so
that's fantastic there's some evidence
in this clip that you can fly in a
sustained manner so maybe it's not
really grounded like armored Core 5 was
but then there's this heavy tank build
that does look like it plays more like
armored Core 5 so maybe there is a bit
of groundedness that depends on your
build there's a bit of everything here
but luckily from made the producer of
the game has clarified stating the
average movement speed across the game
is somewhere between armored Core 3 and
armored Core 5. he says but it does have
these instantaneous bursts of speed and
sudden changes of tempo so combat can
often reach the dizzying heights of say
armored Core IV and according to
yamamura this is achieved thanks to a
button activated movement skill called
The Assault boost assault boost is an
offensive action that helps close the
gap between enemies and lets you quickly
go from long distance to close range it
will also provide some incredible chain
abilities when fighting now most of the
time we see the character assault
boosting on the ground but what about
verticality what about aerial combat
well in past games a jump could be
achieved by boosting from a standstill
position and that's something that we
can see as well at a few points in the
trailer where the legs can play a clear
part in the initial liftoff of your car
character speaking of jumping
specifically though there's a part in
the trailer where the character actually
does this enormous vertical leap but if
you look closely they're actually doing
this on a jump pad which is not unlike
this Spirit Springs that torrent can use
in Elden ring the four vertical lights
here probably extend High into the air
so that it's clear where these jump pads
are located in the world just like you
can see Spirit Springs from far away as
well the fact that these jump pads are
necessary at all suggests to me one of
two things either aerial abilities are
significantly reduced for all mechs
across the board in armored Core 6
compared to previous games or it
suggests to me that maybe aerial
abilities are just significantly reduced
for some heavier builds so these jump
pads might just be a way for all mechs
to achieve verticality in the level and
to be able to progress regardless if
they have a heavy or light design
which brings us to the topic of
customization
so armored core's gameplay doesn't
really just start in the missions it
starts when you first build your Mech in
the garage this is somewhere you return
to all the time and experimenting with
Mech designs and fine-tuning your build
is a ton of fun when you start to
understand the intricacies of all the
parts and how they work together but I
didn't understand this when I first
started playing armored Core at first
you go into the garage to shop for parts
and it's this intimidating chore because
the options and the stats are utterly
overwhelming in these games when I
started I just wanted to put together a
Mech and get back into the missions but
it's funny now that I've played Seven
armored Core games I Now understand a
ton of the intricacies of building and
now it's the other way around I don't
build mechs so that I can do missions
anymore I do missions so that I can
afford new parts and get back into the
garage fine-tuning my Mech to my tastes
is a huge part of the joy for me now and
I get it this is what armored Core is
about it's about taking any Mission and
doing anything for that shiny new part
you have your eyes on and
when I say do anything I really do mean
it you can do some really awful things
in these armored Core missions just so
you can be able to afford Parts it's
great two of the most important parts in
your arm and core are your generator and
your boosters put simply generators
determine how much maximum energy you
have and how fast you regenerate that
energy and boosters determine the power
of your thrust the direction your thrust
favors and also how efficient that
thrust is and then also the dreaded
attribute that you always need to be
aware of is weight because every part in
armored Core has a weight to it and it's
because of this stat that I would argue
that the next most important part of
your Mech are its legs because it's
those legs that determine how much
weight your AC can carry go over your
legs weight limit and you're gonna have
a bad time typically your legs determine
whether you're a lightweight or
middleweight or heavy build but on top
of that legs can also give different
properties to your Mac just listen to
this quote from the game's producer with
armored Core 6 one area we focused on
was to make sure that the customization
aspect is not just about parameters
going up and down and numerical values
changing but how these changes are
reflected in the feel of the action as
much as possible in particular this is
reflected by the leg Parts which control
the AC's movement and in the new trailer
we do see a variety of mechway it's very
clear that their legs are a huge part of
the way they play take the tank with
tread legs for example in previous games
I never found a use for tread legs this
is what it looks like using tread legs
in armored Core 3 but this is what it
looks like using tread legs in armored
Core 6. these legs clearly fundamentally
change the traversal method of the mech
allowing them to charge enemies and
Destroy them and drift as well another
familiar leg type to me with these quad
legs which traditionally have allowed
the player to fire back mounted weapons
while moving as seen here with most
other leg types these back weapons
require you to stand still but in
armored Core 6's trailer these quad legs
can also do this they can jump you high
into the air and then they transform
into these additional boosters which
seem to help this AC hang stationary in
the air and deliver Death from Above if
sustained vertical flight actually isn't
a big part of armored Core 6 then these
could be very unique indeed most Clips
in the trailer do show the player with
standard bipedal legs but even these do
seem to have additional boosters
attached to them which might be cool but
these bipedal legs have to be my
favorites from the trailer they're not
just bipedal legs they're reverse
jointed bipedal legs which is a type
that has traditionally helped you with
jumping and aerial movement springing
you further up into the air so fittingly
we see this Mech do an insanely fast
jump Dodge here and these legs also seem
to give them a unique attack they do a
dismantling kick here that is probably
similar in function to the charge attack
that we saw earlier with the tread legs
and it absolutely obliterates this wheel
Droid this armored Core might be my
favorite one in the whole trailer it's
extremely lightweight and agile and it's
able to move behind this droidica with
blistering speed using an energy shotgun
to blast them before they even know what
hit them now I've had fast ACS in
previous games and they're usually
really hard to play but this is on a
whole nother level of fast ACS and what
makes this one special is its turning
speed turning speed in armored Core
games is traditionally very slow and yes
while you can choose Parts in these
games that increase your turning speed
and while yes in armored Core 4 you can
perform that boost turn it's still slow
but I'm excited to show that the Boost
tone clearly plays a big part again in
armored Core 6 and it's on a whole
nother level because blink and you'll
miss it literally it took just nine
frames for these mechs to boost turn for
that complete 180 nine frames and here
in just 11 more frames the camera
completely catches up as well and it's
now that I assume you know 20 frames
later roughly that the player is fully
locked onto their targets and able to
attack maybe some serious veterans can
correct me here if I'm wrong but I feel
like this is insane for armored Core but
that's not all so the heads up display
is disabled in this trailer so I can't
say for sure but I feel like the way the
camera moves here might suggest that the
player is actually locked on to this
enemy in this clip as they turn and when
I say locked on I mean that in the soul
sense where you press R3 to lock onto an
enemy and the camera just stays centered
on them if I'm right that you can lock
on in this manner that is also
potentially huge for the series as well
because traditionally lock-on and
armored Core doesn't work like it does
in Souls games instead there's usually a
big box in the middle of your screen
that you have to control as you turn
your Mac with the right analog stick and
anything within that box starts being
locked onto if it's within the Box the
size and the shape and the speed and
range of this lock-on is governed by a
part of your armored Core called the FCS
and different FCS Parts have different
sizes and shapes for the lock-on box as
well as different speeds and ranges that
this box targets with it's very
different to souls you take a very
active role in blocking on you
traditionally don't just press one
button and it's done now armed core 4
did have a manual lock-on button that
helped you stay locked onto certain
enemies but it was still pretty loose
and it would fall off if you weren't
facing them properly which happens a lot
because they commonly get out of your
field of view so the fact that this
armored Core 6 Mech and its camera is
able to turn this fast and potentially
retain lock on the whole time I think
has huge implications for the gameplay
it also seems to be happening as well in
this scene as your AC floats around the
enemy here if you look closely they're
watching them the entire time just
smoothly seemingly perfectly so while
from software might be making it easier
to turn around and to control your Mech
even if they do that it doesn't mean the
game is going to get easier no knowing
from software it just means that the
game will have design space to be
difficult in different areas and I think
I know where the game is going to get
more difficult so from what I've played
of armored Core single player missions
very rarely ever require you to actually
read enemy movements and they don't
require you to really avoid their
telegraphed attacks these older games
are not like the souls games in that
regard at most you'll be able to out
maneuver slow missiles at a distance or
try to outpace machine gun fire when
it's closer up to you and this is
especially true in armored Core 4 with
its side boosting but even then you're
so busy flying around most of the time
and watching your energy watching your
ammo staying at the optimal range for
your weapons and just firing two of them
at once you're so busy doing those
things that you don't always have time
to dodge things and it's not completely
required that you side boost everything
and Dodge everything and watching for
telegraphed attacks is really not much
of a thing in these games from what I've
experienced but that is clearly not the
case in armored Core 6. these enemies
especially the bosses are using very
telegraphed attacks here for example
this enemy AC has a chain whip melee
weapon with a vertical slam that I
guarantee you can use your side boost to
avoid this enemy AC has a unique back
unit that over boosts them forcefully
forward into a linear lanced grab attack
that our character narrowly avoids only
to then be caught by it moments later
that's another very clearly telegraphed
attack this spider-like Mech has a slow
laser beam followed by a pincer slam
that the character boosts away from not
to mention there's this female voice
that warns us to watch out watch out and
in another clip warns us about a choral
response from the generator so I think
these things might actually be
mid-battle warnings not unlike sekito's
own attack warning system and this boss
might be the best example though it has
these two giant Club arms that rotate
horizontally in one animation and slam
vertically in another I don't think I'm
wrong when I say these attacks would not
look out of place in a Souls game and
again from my experience with armored
Core these sort of attacks are not
common in those games this is new we
know from past interviews that from
software actually spends a ton of time
in the souls games designing enemy
attacks and animations to be properly
telegraphed to the player so that the
player can recognize patterns and react
appropriately so I will argue that this
is actually a huge design component of
what makes a game souls-like it all I
know the word Souls like is overused and
maimed to death but I think Souls like
combat is very much about the Dodge roll
and the Dodge roll only works if enemy
attacks are very clearly telegraphed so
I think these telegraphed attacks are a
souls-like element and on that note I
kind of want to call out that a lot of
people criticized me for my last video
on Armored Core 6. in that video I
speculated based on solid evidence at
the time that almond core 6 would have
some souls-like elements I argued that
from software have learned things from
the soul series that they will almost
certainly apply to their storytelling
and their combat design and I stand by
that statement in fact I think I'm being
proven right with these telegraphed boss
attacks and potentially also with the
new lock-on method as well man you can
tell I'm really defensive here but like
many commenters misrepresented me as if
I said that this would be dark souls but
with Max but I never said that again I
think this will still be an armored Core
game at its heart but I'm confident that
there will be some new elements that
Souls fans will be quite familiar with
but in the end the game's producer says
it best he says that Ahmed core sex is
an attempt to take both the knowledge
and experience gained from the
development of their previous titles and
combine it with the fun of Mech
customization that the armored Core
Series has always embraced and in this
sense we hope to create a new Mech
action game that is worthy of modern
from software standards specifically by
developing this game with an awareness
of things that from software has always
embraced in its other action games such
as an intricate map structure combat
design that allows players to deal with
enemies by carefully observing their
movements and the ability to overcome
challenging situations with Ingenuity
and creativity
anyway moving on so the devs also make a
clear point that melee weapons are a
huge part of this game so let's talk
about weapons in general in armored Core
in these games typically you have four
main weapon slots you have left hand and
right hand and then left back and right
back two of these slots are usually
active at the same time allowing you to
dual fire a huge variety of weapon types
sometimes you'll want a dual wield
machine guns others you might want to
dual fire both missile slots on the back
or maybe you'll want one of each weapon
type or maybe you're this guy and you
want your back slot to be taken up by an
entire missile cage or maybe you're this
dude and you want to replace your back
slots with an overboost unit there's so
much variety even just in this trailer
alone but one of the most common
loadouts is to have you know a ranged
weapon in your right hand and a melee
weapon equipped in your left hand and in
particular that strategy seems to be the
one is making a big return here in
armored Core 6 because in the trailer we
can see this diverse array of melee
weapons all with different
characteristics there's a familiar laser
blade yes but then there's also a chain
whip that has long range there's a twin
blade that does multiple strikes there's
an energy Lance grab attack there's a
horizontal spinning cleave there's a
flamethrower on this enemy AC not to
mention the pile bunker and cluster bomb
launchers that were seen in the
cinematic trailer there's so much
diversity already in previous games
melee weapons were typically just these
simple blades that all shared the same
attack animations and while they were
extremely damaging they were typically
also quite difficult to hit with if
something is flying or moving more than
five kilometers per hour then you're
just gonna have a really bad time it
gets better in games like armored Core
for Answer where your character really
hones in on that targets but until then
melee weapons were usually something
that you would use as a backup weapon
for when you're out of ammo or you might
want them as a utility weapon to take
out tanky opponents usually I preferred
to dual wield ranged weapons instead
whenever that was possible as that was
the optimal way I thought to deal damage
in most missions and while dual wielding
ranged weapons is clearly possible again
in armored Core 6 based on some of the
loadouts that we can see here I'm
actually feeling tempted to incorporate
melee weapons into my playstyle when I
finally do play this game especially if
lock-on really is a lot more reliable
like it is in the souls games melee is
said to be a big part of this newly
combo based combat when answering a
question on what's new in armored Core 6
the producer states that in the trailer
you may have also seen a part where the
core is deployed by an AC to generate a
shock wave and the pile bunker is then
used on a opponent who is reeling back
from the shock wave this kind of
building combo with multiple weapons is
an appeal of ac6's unique assembly and
combat
and in another response yamunori
encourages players to make use of
something called the Stagger system in
order to break the posture of enemies so
that you can get close for a melee
strike I think that's also a stagger
system sounds like exactly what armored
Core needs to add to give this ebb and
flow to the combat in some fights in
early games fights sometimes just feel
like bunny hopping in a circle around an
opponent and pelting them with
ammunition until they die but having a
posture bar and a health bar should help
fights to become more Dynamic and have
moments where you have to get close to
them and moments where you have to back
off and things like that remember this
game is now being directed by the
legendary Masaru yamamura who I respect
a lot personally because they were the
lead game designer of sekiro and I
believe they were responsible for
sakuro's combat system as well and
secular had my favorite combat system
notably it had the Stagger system in it
and this also went on to inspire Elden
Ring's own stagger system and now it
seems armored Core is getting one as
well yamamura States another addition to
the series combat is a stagger element
if an AC takes too many hits over a
short period of time its altitude
control system will be overloaded making
it vulnerable for a short time both
continuous hits and big powerful strikes
will cause stagger damage encouraging
you to keep up the pressure on the
opponent this damage inflicted to an
enemy's stagger gauge varies from weapon
to weapon it can also be affected by
factors like distance adding additional
strategy in equipping and using these
armaments in combat another part that
I'm extremely curious about are Shields
which are utilized by Max in the trailer
here
here here and here now Shields have been
in armored Core games before as a type
of extension part and while I've
personally only tried them once I didn't
like them I didn't feel like they were
super impactful so you could either
choose from solid Shields that were
heavy or energy Shields that drained
your energy bar when you took a hit and
in this trailer all of the shields we
saw were energy Shields that were
attached interestingly in a back weapon
slot they come out here literally within
one frame which is insanely fast and it
seems like the player is holding them up
manually like they do in Souls games
though it's hard to be sure at this
stage speaking of extension Parts I
wonder if an extension part is
responsible for this action in the
trailer where there's this scan pulse
ability that detects enemies behind
walls or perhaps it's like an armored
Core 5 where there's this dedicated
button that enters you into a passive
scan mode and allows you to Mark and
enemies hiding behind walls locking onto
enemies while they're behind walls is a
staple of the series ever since the
first game it's a great technique if you
have missiles equipped because you can
lock onto enemies with your missiles
from behind a wall and then dash out
shoot your missiles and go back into
hiding and in fact in this armored Core
6 trailer we see these shoulder missiles
react to the lock-on and the missiles
prep as the sensor picks up the enemies
which is a great little detail
it's hard to know at this stage where
all these utility items like scanners
and shields are attached in past games
utility items could exist on your back
they could exist as extensions they
could be inside your AC and sometimes
even armor parts themselves have utility
functions built into them for example
head Parts often have an inbuilt radar
function torso Parts often have
Deployable drones or overboost functions
and there are even some weapon arms that
straight up replace your standard arms
with cannons
finally in the cinematic trailer we see
an EMP attached to what seems like the
core of the unit so that might even be
an option we see this explosion in
actual gameplay as well it reminds me of
assault armor in armored Core 4 which
was this last resort attack that
consumes your Primal armor and
weaponizes it and Deals massive damage
to the opponent at your own expense
what's funny is that in this clip you
can see an enemy Mech attempting this
same animation but they did it a little
bit too late and we get ours off first
priority subject for termination high on
the left
despite being called augmented human
c4-621 earlier in the trailer there's
clearly a bit of intrigue behind our
character because we're also addressed
with another name in that same trailer a
call sign Raven this is an extremely
nostalgic word for long time fans of the
series as in most of the early games the
pilots of armored cores were referred to
as Ravens and the home hub of all Raven
operations were usually called some
variation of a Raven's Nest which
doubled as an organization that mediated
the Ravens contracts with various
employers but regardless of whether our
Raven is a reference here or whether
it's something more armored Core 6 does
take place in a new setting and from
software have been very clear that you
don't need knowledge of Prior armored
Core stories to understand what's going
on in this new game this is because
armored Core 6 takes place in the future
where into Stellar travel is said to be
commonplace so events from past games
are going to be very removed from this
distant star system called Rubicon 3 but
no matter how far they are away it seems
this universe can't escape the greed of
Mega corporations these companies can't
resist the siren song of the coral and
continue to wage war for it despite its
destructive properties having reduced
this planet to Ash contaminating its
climate and turning it extremely cold
therefore the world that we're exploring
is multi-layered it has these shining
mining constructs and energy Farms that
are built on top of the hollowed out
industrial ruins of the old world which
is defended by the indigenous forces of
the planet even now reminds me a bit of
my display that I helped design called
Future Souls Link in the description but
man I'm so excited for this game now
it's been really fun learning to love
the old games just knowing that a new
one is coming and that there's this
purpose to playing all of these and I
think if you have played these old games
then you will also sense just how much
this series will benefit from The Touch
Of Modern from software even Miyazaki
himself has said that past him is
jealous of the sheer budget and
resources that from software can now
bring to bear on their projects it's
clear that older armored Core games
wanted to have the player exploring
these vast Subterranean structures and
they wanted the player to Marvel at the
scale of the world because they were
really ambitious with their old games
but in reality you end up exploring the
same tunnels and you end up exploring
the same sorts of open worlds and they
all have these repeated assets just
compare that to the incredible set
pieces and assets that we're seeing in
this trailer and the color and the
vibrancy and the quality of of these
mechs and everything we're seeing and
I'm just so excited for them to be able
to fully realize and Achieve what they
set out to do so many years ago with
armored Core also some of the coolest
moments for me in these early armored
Core games was when you earned new parts
for your AC during missions rather than
just buying these parts in the shop this
could be done by finding these parts out
in the level or by defeating enemy
armored cores and sometimes you could
even get them just by completing
missions or by S ranking missions with
these clearly more detailed levels in
armored Core 6 and with the familiar
branching Mission structure of the games
confirmed to be making a return I really
hope that discoverable Parts make a
return as well because it really is
exciting to experiment with new parts
and there's no place I prefer to put
weapons to the test than in the arena
best parts of armored Core games for me
have been fighting other mechs and the
arena is essentially boiled down to that
exactly so I was happy to read that
Arenas are returning in armored Core 6
there's essentially going to be these
Arena simulators where you can train
against the armored cores that you might
encounter out in your missions not to
mention also PvP Arenas are confirmed
for armored Core 6 as well and I
guarantee that something that I'm going
to get heavily addicted to when the game
comes out
also on the topic of Storytelling I feel
like from software storytelling has come
so far since they started making these
armored Core games I'll be honest the
old armored Core games do not grab me
with their storytelling the mission
briefings and the cutscenes just put me
to sleep I end up just wanting to play
the game and Skip through them the best
moments for me though in regards to
storytelling is when characters are
actually bantering in the middle of
combat or when the female voiceover
gives you Mid Mission information or
when she debriefs you at the end I also
love being allied with other ACS and
hearing about their struggles or how
they boast during combat I love that
aspect of these games I love that
storytelling and I can tell that those
systems are returning in armored Core 6
as well so that's really great but I've
talked long enough let's end on the
final note of the trailer which I
speculate might be reminding us that we
are a lone mercenary a slave to the
highest bidder used to achieve their
goals let's see how far they can fly
borrowed Wings
subscribe for more armored Core content
and I'll see you next time